and i remember unlocking my phone and
what's up was on and i kind of
closed what's up and clicked on the
camera and the second i clicked the film
i saw what i guess the whole world saw
[Music]
what were you doing the day of the
explosion the day of the explosion
august 4th so joe
um one of my best friends he decided
that he wanted to have burgers
from from this one little place in in
downtown beirut in madame hill is this
very vibrant
little area where you know it's full of
pubs and bars and
restaurants and shops and clubs and all
sorts of things
right about when we finished at this
point it was
around six six pm beiru time
um we heard a
loud explosion and we saw the
the uh the glass screen of the store
facing the burger shop
kind of shake and start the crack so
i felt like the building was going to
collapse on us
so we run out of the store and i pulled
joe and kareem and we get out
and i look to the left
and like it's like kind of like down the
street and that's where the port is so
at the end of the street you kind of get
to an intersection where you can see the
port
and uh i'm kind of standing at the
intersection of the street
where there's actually nothing between
me and the port
from that point to ground zero that
warehouse of basically where
where things started um i was 650 meters
away
and i'm looking at this huge cloud of
smoke
that's just going up and there were
sparks in it and
it looked like things were happening
i mean and in that moment you're kind of
paralyzed at the thought of what's going
on
um i mean i remember thinking
is this war like is was it an attack
what's going on like what are we gonna
do where do we go and i remember
unlocking my phone and
what's up was on and i kind of closed
what's up and clicked on the camera
and the second i clicked the film i saw
what
i guess the whole world saw
what did that impact feel like when i
hit you
it's impossible to describe there's
nothing like it
i mean when you want to describe
something you try to find the closest
thing to it
there was nothing like that feeling um
i mean i'm a i'm a pretty big guy it's
not easy to be thrown around
like i'm like a feather and uh
yeah i mean they say like your life
flashes before your eyes
all i could remember while i was kind of
like flying
um was
that image of the explosion and just the
sound
and being in complete shock of like what
the [ __ ] was that
i remember the first thing i felt was
dust
filling the back of my eyes because the
first thing that gets to you is that
pressure
pressure cloud and then i just flew
i flew and i remember everything
being um
kind of like white and smoke and and
debris of all sorts flying everywhere
and following that the moment of
liftoff came the sound because sound
travels slower
and that was the most horrific
sound that i had ever heard it sounded
as though
something had like murdered the earth
and the earth was roaring back of from
agony and pain
and then light up
at some point i was knocked out so
whether it was for a minute or two i
really don't know
in my head i remember being blown away
and then falling and i mean i was
blown further back um i got up in
inside a restaurant which was i think a
few
like 10 15 meters behind me i had cuts
all over my body from glass and i
assumed it was either from
like while i was in the sky and glass
kind of was exploding everywhere or when
i was
shot back through the the restaurant um
just like cuts everywhere i found that
in my
left foot there was a huge shard of
glass
that had kind of gone through the bottom
um
and usually these things like you
shouldn't remove them because they kind
of become the plug to your body so you
don't
you know bleed out but my first reaction
was
like i can't even walk it's bigger than
my entire leg so i just pulled it out
and i got up and i i went out of the the
restaurant and i didn't even i didn't
even check to see if anything was
was wrong i mean i could move my arms
and my legs so i thought
i was lucky i mean by the time i got up
and i walked out
it looked like a like an apocalypse
it's a very beautiful little area like
all these little restaurants and
pubs and everything was destroyed there
was rubble everywhere every single
glass window whether it was shops or
cars or houses whatever everything had
had exploded
like a railing from balconies were had
fallen
walls had fallen cars had been destroyed
there were the sounds i mean there were
there was a lot of
visual sound yet i couldn't hear
anything um
and it was quite uh terrifying this idea
of seeing
so much sound and seeing people
screaming and people talking to me and i
couldn't hear anything um
so then and i couldn't find i couldn't
see my friends as well i couldn't find
joe and karim so i just started
screaming
and i was screaming their names looking
for them
but i was also screaming hoping that i
could i'll hear my voice
like the things you see you know like
you see these things in movies and you
think you'll be okay when you see them
in real life but
it's not the same um there was a girl
who was standing
i'd say less than a meter away from me
before the blast
um and she was also kind of like looking
onto the port so
i mean essentially we were we would have
had the same effect
she lost her entire cheek so there was
nothing here and you could see like
all her teeth and her like cheekbone um
there were there was a another woman
with her
her her cheek from here was just kind of
like it was if it was just cut
open there was a guy laying
on the floor um
like i think he was unconscious and he
was just covered in blood
there was a group of i guess teenagers
that were bleeding from top to bottom i
mean you can't really tell what the
injuries are just because there's blush
gushing out everywhere so you can't
really tell like what exactly is
happening but i mean
there was blood everywhere thankfully
after a few minutes
i hear like a faint uh scream and it's
essentially it was kareem screaming for
my name so i saw him and i ran to him
and then when we finally see joe um
joe had his t-shirt off and he was
holding it against his forehead
and we kind of like ran to him and were
like what's wrong and he
removes his shirt and there's a huge
cavity
like a huge hole in his forehead so
we're trying to look for our stuff
i was trying to find my phone and we
couldn't find joe's phone
uh we couldn't find any of our stuff and
that's when kadeem who had his phone as
we were looking
just grabbed his phone and took a six
second video
[Music]
you can see me in the video and you can
see joe as well
at that point as we were looking um
joe khanna started to like feel a bit
dizzy and
and uncomfortable and he had to sit down
and he started to like kind of close his
eyes
so i like up until now it was like what
happened to us what's happening what are
we gonna do where are we gonna go
to i think joe's gonna die
and we can't let him die
so i looked at kareem and i said we need
to get out of here now like that's it
forget everything else let's just go
i remember telling kadeem you take joe
and go walk up the street so in the
opposite direction and kind of start
making your way
downtown and kind of like in this other
side of beirut which is just like a few
minutes away
there are like all the big hospitals all
the university hospitals and stuff the
medical centers so we decided that we're
going to make that
journey we're going to make the trip
from within madame
all the way to downtown to um
monitor square is what it's called and
that was a horror movie
just walking through that street was
a horror movie i mean anything that you
could possibly imagine in terms of
um injuries people
like hanging from balconies like just
sitting in like
blood everywhere children like limbs
missing
arms legs throughout that entire street
it was
taking turns carrying joe and then
trying to help people like lifting stuff
off of people
just anything you can do all this time
joe was kind of falling in and out of
consciousness so
i mean his eyes were closed at this
point and his face kind of started to
fill with blood
because so he broke all the bones in his
face
so like it was trying to get like blue
and purple and and
red um
and and we were taking turns like kind
of trying to wake him up and make sure
he stays up and he stays with us
so we finally make our way and we get
down to this open area and we kind of
look around to see if there are any
roads that are leading to
the other side of town and uh far down
by one road we see that there are like
the road is open cars aren't like
destroyed there like you can drive so i
get down there
it's mayhem like it's chaos it's like
apocalypse
scenes like huge tall buildings were
destroyed
i remember seeing this one big building
destroyed and it really shook me like
this is how bad it is
um and i was jumping in front of any and
all cars trying to get someone
to to take us um
i mean people were like losing their
minds no one was kind of like responding
people
just didn't know what to do and we're
kind of driving manically everywhere
um until this one guy i jumped in front
of his car
and i mean i'm pretty sure he must have
freaked out like i was like covered in
blood and joe and kareem were coming
and i said like dude like you have to
take us to the hospital please like
you have to have to take us um and he
was kind enough to
he was just like yeah like get in and
this poor guy
uh christian like i don't know never met
him in life he was just
nice guy we got in the car and he
started driving he he
i think he hit his car like 20 30 times
on our way there
he hit like all kinds of stuff on the
way luckily we got to one of the
hospitals
and i remember right as we were getting
out of the car i was like like are you
fine is your family fine
he's and he's like i can't find my
fiance and i was like
good luck man like thanks for thanks for
dropping us
so we get like one of the doctors we're
like please like you need to help
us like he he's not okay he's like
barely responding he's lost so much
blood he has like a huge hole in his
head
um so she kind of turns her attention to
him
and they put him on a wheelchair and
everything they were operating on people
like left and right on the grounds on
tabletops and
everywhere and
i mean they were asking help from
everyone anyone who could help
would help so while that other doctor
and karim were tending to joe
i kind of was doing anything and
everything that the other doctor was
telling me to do
and this girl came in and she kind of
had like a patch over her eye like a
gauze or something and i kind of like
seated her somewhere i'm like alright
you sit here
and she's like can you just can you see
if my eye is fine because i can see with
this one but i can't see anything with
this one
and she took off that that gauze and
there was nothing there was no eye
um and i was like well can you see me
with the size she's like i can see you
perfectly i'm like that's all you need
to worry about like you're you're good
and here i think i kind of switched into
this little like a bit of a more
positive
kind of outlook because i mean people
were coming into this room thinking
they're either gonna die or
or someone died and it was it was very
intense
at one point they told us that joe needs
to do a ct scan
so they we need to take him to the upper
floors
as they took him in joe's father called
joe's phone
um and akaram had told him where we were
so i was like all right i'll go
you know figure this out you guys take
joe in and uh and get him
so i pick up and uh joe's dad is like
we're here
we're in at the hospital but basically
they managed to get joe in
they had to like pin him down to do the
ct because he wouldn't stop moving
um he was fine they got him out
his dad kind of just threw some gloves
on and helped
staple his his head um
and they took him up to like a room and
he was he was stable he was okay
yeah like just just seeing that everyone
was fine
that's when i was like i was alright
because uh
the the worst thing for me that i kept
thinking about is
i'm not gonna have that conversation
with joe's parents where i have to
apologize
for not making it on time so
thankfully he's all good
we went home and the guys kind of just
like got tweezers and were like picking
glass out of our like kiddim and eyes
like heads and backs and everything in
our
and um yeah we like showered
got some food and i actually went back
to right where the explosion happened um
that same night
looking for like my stuff and the guy's
stuff and
trying to kind of just ground what the
[ __ ] had just happened
went back didn't find anything except
this watch
so my watch survived and uh
yeah that's it was that an emotional
moment going back to the place where you
were when it happened
surprisingly no um i was actually a lot
of anger
at that point like rumors had started to
come out about what had happened
nothing was like confirmed yet but uh
the incompetence of the lebanese
government
definitely like was starting to show
more and more
like no one no one should ever ever have
to experience or live anything like that
so what did you do after the last and
then in a few months after it
so in the in the weeks after the blast
we spent our days
um with joe in the hospital and on the
streets like cleaning up
the streets and building the houses
because
our government is incompetent and uh
they didn't do anything
so it really was like the power to the
people and um
everyone was just in the streets helping
cleaning
we were like getting donations and
distributing like food resources um
yeah and just helping people and
volunteering with all the efforts that
were on the ground
i mean 300 000 people were displaced 6
000
injured 200 plus dead so people needed
help
kind of a little silver lining of kovid
like people were at home it was like
kind of a lockdown in general like
people weren't going out that much
although it was the summer and things
were kind of loosened up but still like
had it been in normal times we'd be
talking like
thousands of casualties not just
hundreds
has anyone been held account for the
explosion until this day
justice hasn't been served no one's been
held accountable
and every attempt to
try to open investigations and to
seek to get um like permission
to hold different government
like political entities accountable are
always either like stopped
or people are threatened um
no path to justice yet no one
no one has been held accountable
and and joe high high is joe and i
joe's awesome he's much better i mean he
he is almost at full recovery but he's
resumed like his normal life and
everything's all right um
but yeah actually i spoke to them
before coming and uh it was actually the
first time that we speak about it
in terms of like the sequence of events
and what happened
and uh
yeah it's just insane to
to remember that we went through that
and how are you doing now there's a lot
of guilt
um like survival for survivor's guilt
because
i mean that girl she was standing right
next to me and her face got like totally
destroyed and
i was right next to her and i'm i'm fine
um
even in terms of joe i mean i was closer
like why him
i feel like if i was standing a meter to
the left or to the right like i wouldn't
be here right now
i don't know how do you go through
something like that without uh
i mean i used to carry my first aid kit
around everywhere now i carry like three
i have one in my bag now um
[Music]
and you're just always like kind of
prepared and ready i mean there's like
the unfortunate
lessons of expecting the worst at any
moment
but it also you walk away from these
things and
like the silver lining is you know that
you're capable
and that you can sustain kind of these
things and
yeah i mean you walk away with some sort
of pride that
realistically you did the best you could
[Music]
so
[Music]
they are all muscle operated so there
are actually no wires or anything
attached
you literally just slip your arm in and
as soon as i'm in there i can move the
fingers
so if i flex my muscles the hand will
open
and if i squeeze my muscles the hand
will close